mr. noodle
when is it okay to unfriend people on
Facebook you don't want to know anymore
when you first got on Facebook you
probably friended a bunch of people you
hadn't seen since high school that was
foolish because now you want to
extricate yourself kind of like high
school graduation all over again perhaps
the greatest theorists of friendship was
18th century man of letters dr. Samuel
Johnson he wrote widely on the top again
for some reason also quite a bit about
his gout Johnson claimed he never forced
himself to read a bad book all the way
through so why not similarly quit
second-rate friends social networks have
since reworked the definition of a
friend to include people like estranged
classmates who used to throw pine cones
at me I mean you but this isn't like
feeling guilty about giving up halfway
to some great piece of literature these
former associations are more like the
entirely unread copy of that
best-selling teen vampire saga your aunt
got you five years ago expel them as
mobs of pitchfork wielding towns folk
would expel shiny shirtless soccer
playing vampires or whatever those books
are about i'm mr. know-it-all which
means i already know whether or not you
are interested in clicking on the
subscribe button you are